Leyna ways made history in September
when she became the first black woman to
win an Emmy for outstanding writing in a
comedy series she co-wrote an episode
for the hit net Netflix series is called
master of none based on her personal
experience of coming out to her family
and now she's a creator and executive
producer thank you very much of a new
drama series call the shy this is a
coming-of-age story based in Chicago
that follows a group of pink people
linked by circumstances in this preview
of episode number two a character
struggles after learning who may have
murdered his younger brother baby didn't
just go to the police
really the policing will be and neither
are you cuz you're gonna promise me okay
I promise I promise I'm not gonna do
nothing I'm just looking at pictures
because I'm busy I'm taking Bobby I
can't stop thinking about him Brandon
keep the promise lean a waist joins us
at the table to discuss welcome this way
and congratulations again to you your
speech was one mini we're talking about
the day after but let's talk about this
the shy because this is a real personal
project for you yeah you're from Chicago
we're reading watching the news and you
thought what
I just thought there are a lot of people
talking about the city who never lived
there we've never survived a winter
there who've never run the streets in
the summer there and I feel like that's
that's the thing that makes me able to
really write these stories and write
these characters because I know them
even these people that I see on the news
who I don't know personally I know them
what's the story you wanted to tell
about your city I just really wanted to
say that you know it's not a jungle it's
not a bunch of hooligans with no hearts
and those souls and that every black boy
isn't born with the gun in his right
hand of how it drugs and is left they're
born with the same amount of hope and
joy is every other little baby in the
world and I think you know sometimes
circumstances and things can affect
their lives and choices they make but I
want to show that we're all human
the idea too that statistics and perhaps
what we show in the media dehumanizes
these stories absolutely it does and I
think particularly especially with
african-american men they're so
dehumanized
and the problem with that is if you do
humanize us so much that you become
desensitized to our deaths and I think
that's so problematic and for me I
really wanted to show the humanity
behind the deadline the headlines
because the next time you hear a story
or a statistic about a young black boy
being shot and killed you know maybe it
won't be background noise cuz you've
seen these characters on the shy and you
were late that's what I liked about it
Lena because it shows that really good
people can make really bad decisions
absolute second and it changes your life
but you've been working on this for two
to three years and you went to TV
executives and that when you pitched it
I understand it didn't go so well well
look I don't know the Shia is not the
most commercial thing you know I know
it's a multi protagonist story there's
not this like cliche hook it's a real
it's a character study and I think
sometimes that's difficult to see
particularly when it's people of color
and I think sometimes they wonder what
what's the hook are they singing to get
out of the hood are they drug kingpins
are they athletes what are they playing
basketball yes you know look at the end
of the day it's like look I understand
all that but sometimes it's just middle
class you know folks trying to get to
work every day trying to raise their
kids trying to get to church when they
can I want to show that sense of
normalcy because I thought you rarely
see characters people of color in a
cinema verite kind of way and I really
want to show that I know you were
reading a lot of James Baldwin and
Langston Hughes yeah we're what ideas
did that give you because I find when I
read things that like sparks your mind
and a whole different bunch of ways I
mean I think it was just a time where I
really kind of wanted to be inspired and
and I'm always reading Baldwin and I was
introduced to him very young and I think
the thing about his work he's speaking
such beautiful prose and he writes so
eloquently but so honestly and I could
found that reading his work you know
even 2015 it was so relevant and I could
just see the people I could you know I
could smell them I could hear them and I
realized I wanted to do that in my
script how long had you been thinking
about doing something like this or
wanted to do something like this you
know I never thought I would write about
Chicago and I definitely never thought I
would write a drama
everything I'd written before that was
community
yeah it was all comedic and so I think
either I know people who know me from
master of none and all that kind of
stuff I think they might be surprised
that my voice does this as well but I
also want to show you know the range
that I have you like some singers want
to show they can do different things as
a writer I kind of want to show my
versatility and I think for me when I
was seeing all these new stories of our
Chicago I got a little frustrated and I
just sort of wanted to express myself
the art you know the Golden Globes at
Oprah's speech I'm curious as the person
who also delivered his speech and people
are talking about your reaction I mean I
think I was really really blown away and
I think a big reason is because you know
I know what she spoke about when she was
talking about sings to me party a I
thought the same thing when I saw how he
Barry I was a high school I've ever seen
that speech and I could still quote it
you know this is all for the
neighborhood faces women of color we now
have an opportunity because tonight this
door has been opened I mean I could
relate so much to that and to see how
that has such an impact on her life and
how that moment made something different
for me and how maybe some young girl
sang me on the Emmy stage may have been
something for them I'm so happy she
caught that out because it's extremely
important for us to be at these award
ceremonies people may think it's like oh
they're just handing out awards things
like that it means so much to these
young kids you know out watching saying
like oh well she did that then maybe I
can do it too you know people are
looking to say I want to be like Lena
wait so by the way guys started as Ava
Duvernay is production assistant look at
you with Ava's ago I know we spent the
time with you in the review fabulous so
congratulations Yeah right thank you so
much really good to meet you think he'll
let me meet you guys the Shire Sundays
on Showtime a division of CBS that you
are watching CBS this morning